in the opening scene we are introduced
to two high school girls named tomoko
and misami who are at tomoko's house for
a sleepover before getting ready for bed
the two friends talk about a videotape
recorded by a boy in easily this tape
supposedly curses the viewer to die
within seven days after his
resistor phone call tamako then
confesses that just last week she and
her friends watched an unusual videotape
and subsequently received an eerie phone
call hearing this Masami connects the
dots and assumes that tomoko may be
destined to meet a similar tragic fate
as they discuss their concerns they
receive an unexpected phone call that
sends shivers down their spines they
nervously pick it up and much to their
relief it is from tamako's mother who
informs her that she will be home late
relieved misami goes to use the restroom
while tomoko proceeds to fetch some
drinks during this moment tomoko
Witnesses the TV mysteriously turning
itself on she promptly switches it off
and returns to the kitchen for her drink
however within moments she senses
someone behind her as she turns around
as she is suddenly attacked by an unseen
presence leading dear
in the next scene we are introduced to
tomoko's Aunt Reiko asakawa a journalist
who is in the midst of conducting
interviews with teenage girls one of the
girls recounts the same cursed video and
the subsequent creepy phone call that
foretolds their death within a week
curious Reiko inquires if anyone has
actually died as a result of this curse
in response the girl reveals that a high
school girl and her boyfriend were
tragically found dead in their parked
car later at the office Reiko checks a
newspaper article detailing the deaths
of a 19 year old boy and his 17 year old
girlfriend in their car in order to gain
more information about the case she asks
her colleague okazaki to find the name
of the high school attended by the
deceased couple that evening Reiko
receives the tragic news of her nieces
result she along with her seven-year-old
son yoichi attends the funeral while
Reiko is busy talking to the relatives
yoichi walks upstairs to tomoko's room
and looks around he is staring at the TV
when his mom walks in and takes him a
similar afterwards Reiko goes to talk to
tomoko's classmates from whom she learns
that tomoko and her three other friends
who had watched the cursed videotape
mysteriously died at the same time on
the same night with their faces Twisted
in sheer Terror Reiko also discovers
that misami the girl who had been with
kamako during her unfortunate end
suffered from severe trauma and is now
hospitalized the following day Reiko
visits tomoko's house and goes into a
room upon looking around she finds a
receipt for a photo album at the same
moment tomoko's mother walks in with a
deeply saddened face and shares how she
found her daughter lying lifeless on the
floor later Reiko retrieves the
developed photos from the lab and learns
that tomoko and her three friends had
gone for a trip to Izu Pacific Land
resort as she goes through the pictures
she stumbles upon one with their faces
blurred and distorted on the same day
Reiko decides to visit Izu Pacific Land
resort and checks on the B4 Cottage
where the four friends had stayed she
presents the picture to the receptionist
inquiring if he noticed anything amiss
as the receptionist checks the reiko's
gaze falls upon an unlabeled tape she
brings it to a room and plays it on the
television the tape features brief
unsettling scenes that appear unrelated
accompanied by jarring sounds and ending
with an
IM well
says
soon as the tape is over Reiko witnesses
an apparition but finds no one when she
turns around this startles her and she
is about to flee but at the same time
she receives a phone call that emits the
screeching sounds from the tape taking
the threat of death seriously Reiko
hurries out of the cabin with the tape
in hand believing that her life is now
limited to just one week Reiko seeks out
her psychic ex-husband ryuji takayama
for assistance she asks him to take a
picture of her only to find her face
blurred in the photograph providing
further evidence of the curse that has
befallen her or maybe ryuji needs a new
camera despite reiko's reservations
ryuji watches the cursed videotape did
bro not see that photo and agrees to
help her a day later Reiko creates a
copy of the videotape for ryuji to
conduct a more thorough analysis after
hours of scrutinizing the footage they
uncover a cryptic message spoken in an
Oshima dialect translating to frolic in
brine goblins be thine Tolkien wrote
this in an effort to decipher this
dialect the two plan to journey to
Oshima the following day until then
Reiko takes her son to her parents house
and spends the night with them that very
night ryuji contacts Reiko and tells her
that the woman in the video is yamamura
shizuko who tragically threw herself
into a volcano four decades ago I don't
think that made it to the Remake later
on Reiko awakens in the middle of the
night only to see The Apparition lying
on the mattress next to her and it
Vanishing in an instant just then she
hears a noise and discovers yoichi
watching the tape this freaks her out
and she asks why he watched it in
response yoichi reveals that tomoko
asked him to do so
stay ryuji and Reiko sail off to Oshima
during their Journey ryuji confesses
that he sensed something when he visited
her house earlier which he believes to
be tomoko's Spirit upon arriving at
Oshima they are picked up by a man named
hayatsu who drives them to their Inn
during the ride Reiko wonders why
shizuko committed the unthinkable and
ryuji explains that she was rumored to
be insane according to ryuji shizuko
gained widespread Fame on the island for
her ability to predict a volcanic
eruption after learning about her
abilities a professor named Dr ikuma
brought shizuko to Tokyo for
experimentation aiming to prove the
existence of extrasensory perception Dr
ikuma suddenly disappeared after being
dismissed by his university but ryuji
doubts that he is still alive after a
while they arrive at their Inn but ryuji
feels something strange as soon as he
steps inside he opens the door to one of
the rooms and comes across the very same
mirror that appeared in the video
shortly after they see shizuko's brother
Takashi Reiko promptly approaches him
seeking information about shizuka's dog
but the old man says that she has no
daughter later that night a hotel staff
member approaches ryuji and Draco and
hands them a picture of shizuko with Dr
ikuma the following morning ryuji
approaches Takashi on the beach and asks
what shizuko was like in response he
claims that she was a strange one as she
used to sit on the beach all day long
staring at the sea ryuji proceeds to
question if shizuko could read people's
minds hearing this Takashi ignores the
question and tries to leave but ryuji
admits that he also has a similar
ability he presses further asking if
Takashi was the one who spread the rumor
about shizuko's abilities but the latter
doesn't want to talk about it the old
man tries to leave but ryuji stops him
during this he has a vision through
which he learns that shizuko prior to
her death gained notoriety following a
public demonstration of her psychic
ability organized by ESP researcher Dr
ikuma with whom she Fair extra sensory
indeed he also learns that Takashi had
attempted to make money off of shizuko's
abilities in the midst of these
Revelations Reiko joins them and also
Witnesses the flashback during the
demonstration everyone believed that
shizuko didn't have any powers and that
she was deceiving them by showing some
magic tricks but then sudden death Among
The Spectators shocked everyone at
leading them to them to consider shizuko
as a monster at the same time shizuko
saw her daughter Sadako there and asked
if she had done this here ryuji
understands that Sadako can kill people
through the power of her thoughts alone
and she presumably did so because she
was unable to tolerate the crowd
badmouthing her mom after learning all
of this Reiko makes a call to okazaki
and asks him to help her find Dr ikuma
and Sadako not long after Reiko receives
a call back from okazaki he tells her
that there is no trace of either of them
ryuji believes that the video is not
from this world and it is sadako's wrath
he claims that Sadako has put a curse on
them a few moments later a man walks in
and informs them that all the fairies
have been canceled due to an approaching
typhoon leaving them stranded on the
island this news devastates Reiko
thinking that she has only one day left
to live and might not see her son again
a short time later Reiko comes to the
sudden realization that ryuji never
received a phone call after watching The
Cursed video as she did back in the
cabin at Izu Pacific Land resort shares
this detail with ryaji sparking
something in his mind and after a lot of
thinking he theorizes that Sadako died
in the land where the Izu Pacific Land
resort stands now and only the people
who watch the video there are
sensing the urgency to go to Izu Pacific
they request Takashi to transport them
there in his boat and thankfully he
agrees as soon as they arrive there
ryuji procures some necessary supplies
from a local store and they set off
toward the resort on their way he asks
about the time when Reiko watched the
video as today as the deadline for its
curse to take effect in response she
tells him that it was around half past
six when she watched it upon reaching
their destination they discover a sealed
well in the cabin's crawl space when
they Place their hands on the well they
experience another Vision where Dr ikuma
brutally assaults Sadako pushes her into
the well and traps her inside following
this ryuji and Reika somehow managed to
remove the Wall's cover and open it
Augie Ventures inside where he finds
remnants of sadako's broken Nails on the
walls indicating her desperate attempts
to climb out determined the duo starts
the process of draining the well in
hopes of locating sadako's remains
personally I hope they don't locate them
as the clock near seven the fear of
impending death overwhelms
ryuji then comes out from the wild and
Rouses her back to Consciousness he asks
her to descend into the well and
continue the training efforts but Reiko
seems to have given up as a result ryuji
reminds her of yuichi wait that's right
I have a son finally convincing her to
proceed upon continuing the draining
process Reiko makes a grim Discovery
sadako's hair emerges from the well and
before long her skull surfaces in the
water a short while later ryuji realizes
that the deadline has passed without any
adverse effects on Reiko this leads them
to believe that the curse has been
broken in the aftermath of this event
the police arrive at the scene and ryuji
drops Reiko back off at home the
following day ryuji is working at his
place when he notices an unsettling
event his television mysteriously turns
on displaying the well featured at the
end of the cursed tape the vengeful
Spirit of Sadako emerges from the well
advances toward ryuji via TV and
instills such Terror in him that it
claims his life meanwhile Reiko who is
trying to contact Ryu during the same
period here's his final cries over the
Fawn and she rushes to his residence but
the body is already taken away by the
authorities she then retrieves the
videotape before returning home
perplexed by the fact that the cursed
seemed to lift from her but not from
ryuji Reiko Ponders the reasons behind
his disparity before long ryuji's Spirit
appears behind her and points towards
her bag she opens the bag and discovers
a copy of the original videotape she
finally deduces that the actual way to
break the curse is by copying the tape
and showing it to someone else within
seven days thus perpetuating the curse
in a never-ending cycle with this
understanding Reiko in a desperate bid
to save her son drives to her father's
place in order to show him the tape
never liked dad much anyway subscribe
for more videos like this turn on
notifications and leave a like to help
the channel out thank you for watching